compass à notre second débat débat de
société consacré ce soir à la voiture
symbole de liberté ou de pollution les
candidats à la présidentielle
s'affrontent aussi sur ce terrain
surtout quand le prix de l'essence
flirte parfois avec les deux euros le
litre cécile 6 où
il est candidat à l'élection
présidentielle le savent les français
seront regardants sur leurs propositions
concernant la voiture 40 millions
d'entre eux en possèdent une et un
français sur deux conduit tous les jours
à droite plusieurs prétendants se place
du côté des automobilistes comme aviez
bertrand dans la voiture j'aime ça la
voiture c'est aussi l'outil de
déplacement et de liberté le massacre de
l'automobile c'est le massacre des
emplois et c'est aussi le massacre d'une
partie du mode de vie de ceux qui
n'habitent pas dans le coeur des
métropoles etc ont besoin de leur
voiture le président des hauts de france
défend notamment une mesure pour faire
baisser le coût de la voiture une aide
mensuelle de 20 euros pour toute
personne qui gagne deux fois moins que
le smic et qui travaille à plus de 20
kilomètres de son domicile
eric zemmour qui n'est pas encore
candidat propose lui de moins punir les
utilisateurs en supprimant le permis à
points clés points maintenant c'est un
racket organisé par l'état vous savez
combien ça coûte
1une un stage d'un stage déjà déjà c'est
infantilisant haut possible les français
peuvent pas travailler pendant d'auto
deux jours et ça coûte 300 euros entre
250 et 300 euros l'éditorialiste aimerez
aussi lever certaines restrictions de
vitesse comme les 80 km heure sur les
départementales où les 130 sur les
autoroutes une proposition à l'opposé de
celle d'anne hidalgo la candidate de la
gauche qui défend le passage de 130 à
110 km heure sur l'autoroute c'est en 30
km heure c'est beaucoup de suite
favorable d'une façon générale à ce
qu'on baisse la vitesse parce que la
vitesse égale accédants la candidate
socialiste fait une autre proposition
également défendue par marine le pen
la réduction de 20 à 5 5% de la tva sur
les carburants elle permettrait aux
français de payer moins à la pompe enfin
le candidat écologiste yannick jadot
propose de réduire l'utilisation de la
voiture en développant le libre service
et le covoiturage
et on va commenter ces propositions et
d'autres parce qu'il y en a beaucoup
autour de cette thématique de la voiture
avec mes invités et 1002 clairement soir
bienvenue soit vous êtes directeur
d'études chez oddo que ça on va
s'appuyer sur le sondage aux docks salle
backbone consulting qui avait été
réalisé le 27 octobre enfin diffusé le
27 octobre par le figaro et vous passez
justement au crible les mesures des
candidats sophie taillé et poli en bon
soir dans ça est venu vous êtes
sénatrice écologiste du val de marne
coordinatrice du projet présidentiel de
yannick jadot membres du parti
génération jean louis thiériot bonsoir
bonsoir bienvenue a aussi député l air
de seine-et-marne soutien de valérie
pécresse et vous publiez de gaulle le
dernier réformateurs c'est aux éditions
tallandier on a également avec nous en
visioconférence le sociologue jean viard
bonsoir directeur de la recherche
associé au cevipof cnrs ces jeux cités
votre dernier livre la révolution que
l'on attendait est arrivé c'est aux
éditions de l'aube mathieu croissandeau
est resté avec côté évidemment un
premier chiffre sortie de l'étude donc
ça 54% des français 58 % des
automobilistes qui affirment qu'ils
accorderont une attention importante aux
propositions des candidats sur la
voiture je vais reprendre certains des
chiffres qui étaient dans le dos dans le
sujet
c'est un thème relativement nouveau
de le voir prendre cette importance
assez baird alors ces dernières années
giresse depuis quelques années
effectivement la voiture prend une place
importante alors ça l'a toujours été un
une certaine mais il faut se rappeler
des années soixante dix où il y avait
des vraies problématiques autour de la
sécurité routière où on s'opposait à la
ceinture de sécurité ou à des choses
comme ça aux limitations de vitesse déjà
à l'époque mais pendant longtemps la
voiture n'a pas été vraiment un objet
politique et là on se rend compte ces
dernières années que ça devient un vrai
objet politique les candidats s'opposent
sur différentes propositions où on aura
l'occasion d'en parler on voit bien
qu'il ya des positionnements politiques
fassent qui s'opposent à la voiture
d'audi soutiennent les automobilistes
font rappeler quand même que les
automobilistes c'est l'essentiel des
français à la quasi totalité des
français sont des automobilistes dont
quand on parle de voitures on parle à
tous les électeurs et donc c'est
forcément un sujet important pour pour
eux et donc pour les candidats à la
présidentielle c'est un marqueur
politique d'une d'une certaine façon est
faux c'est ce que vous diriez sa sophie
taillé et poli est ce que c'est un
marqueur entre guillemets
facile pour yannick jadot ou est-ce que
ça voilà dans sa position dans en étant
le candidat d'europe écologie les verts
finalement il est là où on l'attend sur
la voiture écoutez je crois que la
voiture c'est assez le marqueur d'une
époque et si ça devient aujourd'hui
effectivement un débat c'est parce que
on est et on doit changer d'époque donc
effectivement beaucoup de questions
doivent se poser sur la voiture et les
écologistes et yannick jadot nous
pensons effectivement qu'on doit
vraiment se serait interrogé très
fortement sur la place de la voiture sur
cet outil non pas pour le pour le
diaboliser il est extrêmement utile et
même indispensable à de nombreux de
nombreuses françaises et français donc
bien entendu mais il faut vraiment qu'on
mesure l'impact qu'il a sur
la pollution de l'air sur l'émission de
gaz à effet de serre etc et donc qu'on
réorganise les choses dans notre pays
précédemment je dirais c'est 20 30 40 50
60 dernières années on a organisé tout
autour de la voiture il faut
véritablement qu'on change de modèle
mais il faut certainement pas le faire
sur le dos des ménages modestes ou
encore moins des précaires jean louis
thiériot quand xavier bertrand dit on
l'a vu dans le dans le reportage moi la
voiture j'aime ça d'accord avec lui oui
alors je sais pas si on aime ou on
n'aime pas mais moi je pense que la
question s'est passé là la question
c'est qu'est ce que c'est que le
quotidien des français le quotidien des
français c'est qu'un français sur deux
utilise sa voiture tous les jours c'est
à peu près ce que donne votre sondage
est que pour aller travailler dès qu'on
est dans la france des périphéries dans
la france rurale moi je suis élu de
seine-et-marne dans mon département si
on n'a pas de voiture on n'a pas les
moyens et les transports en commun ne
pourront pas le régler de toute façon
parce que c'est un habitat avec de
toutes sortes de petites communes on a
impérativement besoin de sa voiture
aujourd'hui la voiture ça n'est plus le
symbole que ça a pu être un moment on
pense aux mythologies de roland barthes
par exemple où la voiture était le
symbole de toutes les projections
sociale je crois que la voiture
aujourd'hui c'est une nécessité et quand
vous avez un revenu modeste mais on y
reviendra sur la question financière
qu'un plein c'est 70 euros et que vous
en faites quatre dans le mois et bien si
on n'a pas une politique qui permet
d'avoir une voiture accessible les gens
n'iront plus travailler c'est une trappe
à inactivité et c'est le marqueur d'une
souffrance si on l'a vu avec le gilet
jaune l'un des
élément qui a allumé la colère sociale
ces quelques centimes de plus contre le
gasoil si on veut défendre
l'environnement et je suis de ceux qui à
droite croit qu'il était impératif à
ingrandes politique de l'environnement
on ne le fera pas en tout cas en
opposant la fin du mois la fin du monde
jean viard quand les candidats parlent
de voiture est ce que vous diriez que
c'est un peu une synthèse impossible
servent que effectivement tous les
français se sentent concerné mais
comment parler en même temps au aux
habitants des des centres urbains et à
ceux des campagnes
la majorité des entretiens n'ont pas de
voiture et 70% des français habitent
dans des maisons et jardins donc souvent
isolés on doit les lotissements et c'est
bon il faut bien voir ça en français à
16 millions de maisons avec jardin et 12
millions d'appartements et en plus c'est
12 me en appartement il y en a quand
même 4 millions qu une résidence
secondaire ou encore au logement qu'ils
en la voiture pour les week ends à la
campagne thaksin et il faut avoir ce
match quand ils font partie de la vie
des gens il faut partir du fait que dans
les milieux populaires on n'achète
jamais de voitures neuves au c'est un
objet quasiment inconnue la voiture
neuve ce qu'on achète ses lois turquie à
4 5 ans vous allez monsieur l'achète 4 5
ans picrate la voiture à 7,8 en me
levant la bad as me la prend et monsieur
prend une nouvelle voiture de 4 5 ans
donc une voiture ça tombe sur 10 15 ans
le problème c'est comment ce modèle là
on l'analyse moi je crois qu'il faut et
on va pas le changer c'est à dire le
périurbain les maisons qui sont
construites on va pas les anglais
pensent plutôt de la demande des
français céderont densifie le père est
en bas juste à côté des 1000 pas loin
pas dans les terres agricoles mais pas
qu'on supprime cette situation concerne
je crois que l'ennemi c'est la pollution
c'est pas la voiture en fait est que en
ce moment il ya parfois une idéologie
moyer dans la ville moi j'aime le vélo
c'est génial en ville et s'ils veulent
ont sacré de la segmentation social
basque une ville c'est du brassage entre
les quartiers les lointains les
quartiers pour les quartiers riches ces
trains si le brassage diminue la
segmentation sociale augmente mais il
faut mettre tout ça sur la table et mal
quoique le seul adversaire c'est la
pollution et qu'il faut pas se tromper
un peu une idéologie anti voitures qui
me laisse un peu perplexe parce que pour
moi c'est un peu des gens des villes qui
ont pas besoin mais moi je suis un rural
oui j'ai une voiture j'avais même deux
d'ailleurs parce que je suis né une
voiture bon ferment le dard dard et
promener mon chien donc ciblé il c'est
pour ça que je dis faisons très
attention parce que c'est une minorité
qui en fait que se passer de voiture
minorité qui peut en louer qui peut
l'utiliser et donc travaillons plutôt ça
une logique écologique des voitures
électriques ces choses là je crois que
c'est plutôt un lâche d'orientation qui
me semble correspondre la demande de la
société sophie taillé et poli est ce que
ça suffit finalement de remplacer les
voitures thermiques actuelles par des
voitures
électriques sans changer profondément le
modèle alors je crois pas que ça suffise
parce que on sait aussi que c'est
peut-être pas mal en termes de santé
publique il ya beaucoup de trajets de
petits trajets de trajets courts qui
peuvent se réaliser il n'y a même pas
besoin de vélo à pied et qui aujourd'hui
sont faits par beaucoup de françaises et
français encore en voiture pour des
questions aussi de rythme de vie pour
des questions de facilité pour des
questions de confort cetera et cetera
d'eau il ya quand même des choses qui
sont en train d'évoluer mais qui doivent
encore évoluer davantage après il est
évident que dans le projet écologiste
est pas un projet qui est contre la
voiture c'est effectivement un projet
qui est contre les pollutions et pour
aussi la relocalisation et c'est aussi
le lien social et la proximité on a
aujourd'hui et c'est la raison pour
laquelle la voiture a pris tant de place
et pourquoi il faut là certainement au
travail et à faire en sorte qu'elle
quelle soit moins présente on a des
l'étalement urbain 1 avec c'est vrai
beaucoup de gens qui vivent loin de tout
commerce me compris même d'une simple
boulangerie donc c'est aussi de faire
repos la risée davantage avec des
centres urbains plus plus plus divers -
gros aussi pour faire en sorte que la
vie soit plus en proximité mais
j'ajouterais pour terminer que les plus
modestes pollue quatre à cinq fois moins
que les moins modestes alors entre les
1% les plus pauvres et les 1% les plus
riches là on est à plus de 10 fois donc
je dirais que le vrai souci dans notre
pays des battles mais non dans france
c'est pas tant la consommation des
personnes qui ce qu'ils ont en revenus
moyens ou modestes et qui prennent leur
voiture elles peuvent continuer comme ça
si les efforts sont faits du côté de
celles et ceux qui ont beaucoup de
moyens et qui partent en vacances à la
martinique pour soi c'est bien d'aller à
la matinée à mon avis ils vont pas en
voiture à la martinique non mais
forcément
il faut parler mobilité globalement il
faut parler mais six mois la honte et de
l'aube un
voyage qui pourrait certainement
prescrit de réalité pardon vous
interrompez j'entends des gens viennent
tout à l'heure pendant que j'entendais
parler du marché de l'occasion
aujourd'hui des voitures qui s'achète le
plus sur le marché du pl occasion cd
diesel c'est encore des diesels non mais
ils font et donc oui c'est c'est pas si
facile de faire évoluer sur tout le
monde et personne ne prétend à la
facilité par contre il faut prétendre à
une certaine forme d'ambition pour
mettre des moyens pour permettre cette
transition y compris faire en sorte que
des ménages modestes est accès à des
voitures peut-être un peu plus coûteuse
mais beaucoup plus vertueuses et ça
c'est extrêmement important il ya des
propositions sur la table des
facilitations de prêts ou même des aides
à la conversion qui doivent être
davantage ciblées vers les ménages
modestes et plus important pour les
ménages modestes pour éviter est
effectivement que les diesel ne vit une
vie beaucoup trop longue alors on va
parler du coût du carburant vous l'avez
évoqué tout à l'heure jean louis
thiériot et me leclerc est évidemment au
coeur des préoccupations et qu'en ce
moment français comment ils réagissent
aux propositions des candidats tiens par
exemple baissé la veille de tva sur les
carburants de 20 à 5 ennemis alors c'est
drôle parce qu'on retrouve anne hidalgo
et marine le pen à celle proposée
s'étaient assez surprenant d'ailleurs de
la part de daniel gauvin tout le monde a
été un peu surpris de cette proposition
compte tenu de sa position à paris
plutôt anti voitures entre guillemets
mais finalement ça vient soutenir une
autre problématique dont on a commencé à
parler c'est le pouvoir d'achat c'est
une vraie problématique de campagne on
voit aujourd'hui et les français quand
on leur dit pas la voiture qui est déjà
je rappelle 1 11 % du revenu disponible
des français va dans la voiture donc que
ce soit l'achat de la voiture le
carburant le l'assurance etc etc c'est
quand même 11 % du revenu disponible
c'est colossal dans un budget et donc
les français dès lors qu'on leur propose
des mesures qui leur permettent de
baisser ce coup et bien ils soutiennent
très très largement 88% des français
sont favorables à cette idée de baisser
la tva dans un contexte on vous voit le
carburant a explosé mais oui alors il ya
eu il ya eu le chèque inflation deux du
gouvernement
jean louis thiériot qu'est ce que vous
proposez vous pour pour soutenir le
pouvoir d'achat des français sur la
voiture un vaste plan de notre d'écouté
il ya différents biais vous avez entendu
la proposition de xavier bertrand moi je
pense que on peut avoir une solution
beaucoup plus simple parce que je suis
très réservé sur la politique déchets
qu'on fait des chèques pour tous surtout
en période électorale c'est tout
simplement ma une taxe qui est relaté
icpe faisons-en davantage une taxe
flottante et quand le coût du carburant
augmente on baisse le montant de la taxe
à l'idée que ceux de monsieur de madame
hidalgo ou de madame le pen sur la tva
c'est tout simplement contraire au droit
communautaire puisque ça veut dire qu'on
passe d'un taux de 20 % un taux de 5 5%
ça supposerait l'accord des 27 puisqu'on
a déjà trois catégories pardon de faire
un peu de la technique donc c'est tout
simplement en tant que tel pas
applicable en revanche faisons une té i
cpe flottante on baisse le montant de la
taxe quand les cours montent et c'est
tout à fait efficace a déjà existé par
le passé on se rappelle c'était pendant
le gouvernement jospin restaurer la tpp
flottante qui avait été facile à baisser
quand les prix avaient augmenté mais
très difficile à remonter le
gouvernement s'y était même refusé à le
faire il a fait venu que la droite
repasse ensuite pour que brooks et
remonte c'est très compliqué de jouer
une fois vous avez baissé
quand on a vu la flamme à sion des
gilets jaunes quand on voit les
problèmes que ça pose je pense que c'est
plus simple le problème de la tva c'est
tous simplement qu aujourd'hui dans le
système légal qu'on a on peut le changer
mais il faut que les 27 soit d'accord et
là bon courage clip oui moi sur cette
question là j'ai attention aujourd'hui
on le voit bien ce sont les françaises
et les français qui sont modestes qui
ont des revenus pas très élevés qui sont
en difficulté bon alors si on fait une
mesure de tva comme ça bête et méchante
je dirais on touche tout le monde y
compris ceux qui ont fait le choix
d'acheter des super grosse bagnole parce
qu'ils adorent ça je sais pas quoi et
qui consomment beaucoup et c'est assez
les mettra en forcément je suis pas en
tout cas moi c'est pas notre ne sais pas
le modèle que
57%
si ça leur fait plaisir je vois pas
pourquoi nous on viendrait supprimer des
recettes de l'état qui après paye les
fonctionnaires les hôpitaux etc pour
elle donc c'est bon ça s'ils ont les
moyens très bien mais qu'ils l'assument
jusqu'au bout donc c'est pour celà
raison pour laquelle nous considérons
que cette baisse de la tva comme ça elle
est allée elle est trop large et elle
est pas bien ciblées et que si
effectivement on doit aider un certain
nombre de françaises et de français à
surmonter cette crise que tout le monde
pense temporaire le strat l on verra
c'est mieux d'avoir des déchets et des
mesures de pouvoir d'achat qu'ils soient
qu'ils soient ciblées si on commence à
chaque fois à arroser trop large gérer
on va quand même avoir un certain nombre
de problèmes et on a souvent des
parlementaires l air ou en marche qui
nous disent attention attention vous
allez mettre en difficulté le le budget
de l'état moi je dis attention je pense
que des mesures ciblées sociales sont
indispensables parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de françaises et français qui ont besoin
de leur vie pour aller travailler ou
pour aller voir leur famille ou pour fin
pour la vie quoi tout simplement et on
ne peut pas l'ignorer mais attention à
bien cibler la parution de valérie
pécresse qui propose d'augmenter la
participation
des entreprises
sur les forfaits transport à partir du
moment où il n'ya pas de desserte par
les transports en commun c'est aussi une
proposition extrêmement intéressante on
va parler maintenant des la vitesse avec
la thématique de notamment des des
capellans
km/heure faut-il revenir partout aux 90
km heure mario viau vous pouvez nous
rejoindre merci alors je vais donner de
deux chiffres qui sont dans le sondage
hoxha pour le cigare aux 65 % des
personnes interrogées pour un retour des
50 km heure en ville et 84% pour le
retour des 90 km heure sur tout les
départementales mesures qui avaient été
fortement contestée au sénat
effectivement pour rappel cette mesure
avait été prise en 2018 dans le cadre
d'un plan de lutte contre l'insécurité
routière elle visait à enrayer la hausse
de la mortalité sur les routes mais cet
abaissement de la vitesse de 90 à 80
km/heure avait suscité une vraie sont au
fond et en particulier au sénat à
l'époque cette décision avait été perçue
par les sénateurs comme je cite le
paroxysme du judaïsme la majorité
sénatoriale déplorant une décision prise
sans concertation avec les élus éloigné
des réalités locales et de préconiser
une réduction de la vitesse uniquement
sur les routes accidentogènes et
l'abandon de l'abandon de sa
généralisation à tout le territoire et
écouter justement ce qu'en disait à
l'époque le sénateur jean yves roux
c'était lors des débats en séance il est
critiquable d'avoir fait le choix d'une
application uniforme de la règle du 80
km sur l'ensemble du territoire national
la sécurité routière est bien sûr un
élément fondamental mais elles ne
peuvent pas être le critère unique en
matière de délimitation de vitesse
l'enclavement des territoires en est par
exemple un autre tout aussi fondamental
alors défini sénateurs ont été en partie
entendue puisque la loi mobilité votée
en 2000 9a finalement assoupli la mesure
des 80 km/heure en donnant la
possibilité aux maires mais aussi aux
présidents des départements de procéder
à des exceptions et aujourd'hui un tiers
des départements a rétabli au moins
partiellement les 80 km/heure et quatre
départements l'ont totalement fait c'est
le cas de l'allier du cantal de la
creuse et de la corrèze et puis le
discours des sénateurs change pas
vraiment sur ces questions de mobilité
de place de la voiture il prône la
décentralisation des décisions et car
dans tout ça c'est la méthodologie 1 qui
pose problème mais pour le sénateur
centriste hervé maurey le vrai débat
finalement qui doit s'instaurer ce n'est
pas la question de la vitesse ou du prix
de l'essence mais plutôt quelle place et
quel considération pour les territoires
ruraux dans les politiques publiques
écouter le
[Musique]
moment marie vielle et coupé des
réalités
il faut donc entendre davantage les
réalités et les contraintes des
territoires mais regardez aussi les
chiffres en effet depuis la mise en
place des 80 km/heure un premier rapport
d'évaluation est sorti on le doit aux
serema et il révèle que la mortalité sur
les routes a diminué avec 331 décès de
moins entre juillet à 2018 et décembre
2019 merci marion pour ces précisions
jean viard je reviens vers vous vous
écoutez depuis tout à l'heure je
voudrais faire de nouveau intervenir
dans ce débat parce que vous aviez pris
position sur cette question des 80 km
heure à l'époque en parlant d'une erreur
politique pourquoi
mais moi je suis un rural si vous voulez
donc j'avais un peu l'impression que
c'était quand même une décision c'est
toujours pareil pour la ville quoi et en
plus c'est un je vous rappelle quand
même moment il y avait les 80 km/heure
l'augmentation du prix du diesel et puis
il y avait aussi les nouvelles mesures
de contrôle technique des véhicules
honnêtement les ronrons s'était senti un
peu mis de côté quoi parce que il ya et
c'est ça qui pose problème c'est que
l'explication politique posé problème
est maintenant excusez moi mais si le
problème c'est qu'on n'y comprend plus
rien moi je roule beaucoup peuvent
suivre des conférences partout vous
savez pas si vous le voulez à 80 ou 90
donc c'est quand même un peu compliqué
parce que le département c'est pas un
territoire de watsa je m'excuse on les
traverse les départements il ya ceux qui
habitent dedans mais même eux ils
ensemble tout le temps puisqu'on fait en
moyenne 70 km par jour et par français
on peut avoir la taille de mobilité si
oui ou non ils savent a plongé dans la
plus grande perplexité mais à l'époque
effectivement j'avais dit ça excusez-moi
l'égide des journées ils sont bien
médecin est ce à dire que tous et qui
sait les gilet jaune ben ali fille des
joueurs c'est les gens qui étaient allés
construit des maisons dans des
lotissements ou qui habitait dans des
villes lointaines saint dizier tout ça
vous savez c'est des gens qui vous
disent j'habite à une heure de paris ou
de lyon ils vous disent pas d'abord où
il habite ils vous disent je suis à
l'extérieur 2 bon c'était ça le coeur
des gilets jaunes et les milieux
populaires des bosseurs qui s'était
acheté une maison tu vois la femme était
salariée alors que la maman ne l'était
pas et en gros il y avait deux salaires
le deuxième salaire rembourser la maison
il avait deux diesel un peu plus en est
une maison pas bien isoler et à un
moment il ya une fracture culturelle qui
le base dans toutes nos sociétés excusez
moi et une révolte du périurbain
populaire aux etats-unis c'est la torah
trump partout en france il ya une vraie
révolte parce que ces milieux populaires
qualité en promotion sociale si vous
voulez c'est aussi celui qui a refusé la
mixité sociale dans les quartiers faut
pas non plus être trop gentil et ce
milieu-là s'y sentir rejeté dans son
modèle culturel et ça c'est une vraie
question politique s'ils voulaient après
la question de la vitesse etc quoi
qu'ils font tous pensé en même temps
mais il faut réintégrer ce projet des
milieux populaires d'être propriétaire
d'une petite maison avec un jardin
chez un point d'eau c'est ça le coeur de
70 % des gens vivent comme ça ils vont
partir de ce désir de vie et le
regardait alors qu'on dirait qu on règle
des questions techniques et me leclerc
eric zemmour et c'est ce qui fait quand
il propose
de revenir à 90 km sur toutes les
départementales on se doute que c'est
oui a reçu bhl majoritairement par
ailleurs les forces qu'il avait à dire
qu'il ya quelque chose de démagogique
d'une certaine manière il sait
parfaitement que c'est une mesure qui a
posé problème est donc l'annoncé c'est
pas très compliqué en soi ça n'engage
pas à grand chose et il sait qui pourra
séduire une partie des français qui sont
attachées sahel c'est vrai que comme le
disait jean viard au moment où ça a été
annoncé ça a posé une vraie
problématique dans l'opinion et on a vu
que ça ça ne plaisait pas à l'essentiel
les français il ya d'autres mesures anne
hidalgo a
rapidement évoqué la baisse de la
vitesse sur 130 sur autoroute de 130 à
110 ça on l'a testé aussi c'est 75% des
français qui y sont opposés donc dès
lors qu'on touche à la vitesse des
voitures et comme le disait jean viard
en fait on touche aussi au quotidien des
gens au quotidien ils prennent leur
voiture vous avez plus de la moitié on
est à 70 % dans les territoires euros
donc quand vous touchez la vitesse vous
toucher au quotidien en autant de
déplacements et donc autant disponibles
pour faire pour faire autre chose sophie
calle polluants la vitesse c'est quoi
votre est-ce qu'il faut voilà par
principe baisser la vitesse sur les sur
les routes de france c'est le signal
qu'on envoie d'une certaine façon bref
quand même se poser la question de la
sécurité routière et de remettre à plat
la politique
de prévention et je pense que c'est
quand même un peu le coeur du sujet
parce qu'effectivement quand on est au
volant de sa voiture et j'en suis on a
envie d'être le plus rapidement arriver
mais qu'on a envie quand même de le
faire en toute sécurité donc je crois
qu'il faut pas aller c'est peut-être pas
le plus populaire vous dites il faut
réduire la vitesse en tout cas enfin en
tout cas je pense qu'il faut très
clairement ce le poser dans cette danse
est
dans cette logique là parce que c'est
quand même on le voit et on en a tous
plus ou moins des exemples plus ou moins
récents enfin je veux dire la route elle
elle tue donc il ya certainement des
mesures à prendre peut-être celle ci est
la meilleure peut-être il y en at il
d'autres aussi mais je crois qu'il faut
pas non plus uniquement être dans le
fait de caresser les gens dans le sens
du poil voilà c'est cette question elle
mérite d'être d'être posée est ce débat
respecter ce qui n'est pas le cas là de
certains certaines personnes qui
participent au débat public s concevoir
leur toit est-ce que vous parlez vous
aussi de démagogie est ce que c'est un
terme que vous employer pour qualifier
la proposition dessus sur le mot sur le
sujet de la vitesse non nous dans le
département de cinéma que j'ai été
président du département de seine et
marne dès qu'on a eu la possibilité de
remettre une partie des routes à 90 nous
l'avons fait c'est à dire qu'on a
vraiment fait de la déco à l'argument
mon terrain il était simple c'est que
c'est le quotidien des français tout ce
que disait d'ailleurs monsieur vierge
suis totalement d'accord il ya des
routes sur lesquelles ça n'est pas
dangereux il ya d'autres routes qui
effectivement sont dangereuses qui
tourne beaucoup donc moi je pense
vraiment qu'il faut faire de la dentelle
est sélectionné c'est le choix que tient
prennent de lisibilité on était la
condition et à condition d'être
l'assistant après quand on parle de
sécurité c'est bien d'interdire la
circulation à 90 mais quand vous voyez
notamment sur les nationales moi je vois
dans mon département de seine-et-marne
l'a36 où la n 4 où vous avez des routes
nationales avec des ornières qui sont
dangereuses notamment pour les motards
de dire ça aussi c'est une mesure que
l'état doit prendre quand on parle de
démagogie donc au moins les 90 80 c'est
pas la démagogie si vous me parlez de
l'autre proposition de monsieur est môme
on y viendra prête sur le permis à
points là on est dans la démagogie à
l'état pur j'étais maire d'une commune
de 200 habitants en quelques années à
deux reprises je suis allée annoncer à
des familles le décès d'un fils ou d'un
père
le permis un point à son utilité
peut-être qu'on peut il toucher à la
marge mais il a son utilité on ne joue
pas avec la sécurité des français ça a
été un des éléments qui a sauvé des vies
et là à mon sens on est au coeur de la
démagogie et les responsabilités il ya
des vies à sauver pour parler maintenant
du permis à points avec cet élément 21
pays sur les 27 pays membres de l'union
européenne
utilise un permis à points l'argument
d'eric zemmour c'est à dire que c'est
une machine à cash et que c'est pas
vraiment où on peut pas quantifier le
nombre de deux morts ou d'accidents
évités grâce au permis à points qu'est
ce que ça vous comment vous réagissez à
sa sophie calle paulien écoutons nous
dire ce que j'en pense je suis convaincu
que ça m'est arrivé mais des dizaines de
fois peut-être des centaines de fois
depuis que j'ai mon permis de faire un
peu plus attention parce que il y avait
un radar et parce que je me disais à
perdre un point et donc je sais pas si
je me suis sauvé la vie si j'ai sauvé la
vie de quelqu'un mais je suis persuadé
que psychologiquement ça a joué bien sûr
que ce sont des mesures de prévention et
qui sont qui ont prouvé leur efficacité
alors c'est vrai c'est désagréable mais
si tout le monde il n'y avait sur terre
que des petits anges qui faisait
toujours que tout bien qu'ils
respectaient les règles de sécurité etc
ça se saurait malheureusement ce n'est
pas le cas donc il faut mettre en place
un certain nombre de mesures de
prévention et de coercition je crois que
monsieur zemmour est très très très très
heureux d'en proposer d'état toujours
pour les mêmes 1 en discriminant les
gens donc un peu un peu de décence un
peu de décence il ya effectivement déjà
d'aider des vies en jeu et donc oui cc
c'est normal aussi de devoir respecter
des règles les apprendre les réapprendre
si on les a oubliés la conduite n'est
pas n'est pas si simple elle devient
automatique quand on conduit depuis
longtemps mais il ya quand même des
choses arme et remplacé régulièrement
pour repasser son permis ou avant et ça
veut dire que c'est effectivement on
sait ans l'âge ça ça veut dire que c'est
effectivement on a commis quelques
imprudences il est peut-être bon de
retourner un petit peu sur les bancs de
l'école pour remettre un petit peu les
idées en place et ses pros et ces
programmes doivent être doivent être
conçus pour faire en sorte de mettre les
gens devant leur responsabilité
attention quand vous faites ça les
risques c'est ça attention quand vous
faites ceci les risques c'est ça je
pense que c'est là qu'on en avait pas
un tir de jeu c'est pas soixante dix ans
la deûle avec l'accession du seuil de
l'âge sur l'ailleurs serait d'ailleurs
problématique ci ont décidé ça il faut
repasser des épreuves de vue de
d'habileté pour pour valider son permis
c'est non par exemple en italie je crois
que c'est pas une question d'âge ce
serait bizarre de fixer un seuil à des
gens qui en renfort au même âge n'ont
pas dû non pas du tout les mêmes les
mêmes compétences les mêmes mêmes
capacités etc mais je
très impopulaire
effectivement
les thèmes des médecins qui conseille et
moi j'avais déjà connu de dire voilà il
faut tout revoir il faut vérifier que je
pense que ça c'est que c'est extrêmement
important quand même oui
pour revenir sur le période permis à
points il ya quand même un principe
d'égalité dans le permis à point parce
que si vous n'avez que le principe d'une
amende est bien plus on est riche plus
d'une certaine manière on se moquera de
d'avoir été attrapé par radar alors que
le permis à points mais il ya un
principe d'égalité tout le monde est au
même niveau même s'il y a quand même les
stages de récupération de points qui
permet de moyennant 300 400 euros comme
le dit eric zemmour de récupérer des
points mais c'est surtout c'est une
infime proportion des conducteurs qui
perd son permis à point fort et à mettre
un chauffard pour perdre les 12 points
nous et peut-être tous arrivé de perdre
1 2 3 points mais ça revient
automatiquement au bout de quelques
années quand vous avez bien conduit j'ai
parfois peur des douze faut le faire
problème c'est que la figure du
conducteur est devenu totémique en
politique les verts
une partie des verts en tout cas un yves
contassot avait promis l'enfer
d'automobilistes vous souvenez apparaît
donc faisons de la figure
d'automobilistes sont responsables de
tous les maux al'inverse on trouve que
le cycliste est la nouvelle figure
formidable ce comportement sur les
routes c'est souvent les mêmes les mêmes
qui confuse et mal ce qu'on voitures
conduisant ou se conduisent mal en vélo
il n'y a pas pas de manichéisme là
dedans donc il faut c'est une éducation
qu'il faut refaire tout le monde on
conduit un vélo conduisent une voiture
conduisent une voiture électrique et
puis elle symbole de liberté associée à
la voiture c'est là-dessus qu'un système
marine le pen lors de son discours de de
rentrée c'était à fréjus 12 septembre
dernier en écoute de garantirait aussi à
tous la liberté de circulation or la
liberté de circuler c'est évidemment
celle de le faire à un prix raisonnable
ainsi la nationalisation des autoroutes
paraîtra de stopper l'inflation des prix
des péages de la même base façon
l'explosion du prix des carburants doit
être à tout prix du lait à la liberté de
circuler c'est aussi la liberté de
pouvoir le faire partout des
restrictions insensé imposé par les
verts et qui demain interdira aux
voitures diesel ou voiture trop âgées de
se rendre dans les grandes villes sont
une infamie parce que l ces mesures à
prendre bien évidemment les plus
modestes et nos compatriotes d'ailleurs
qui vivent dans la ruralité alors on
parle à la question de la
nationalisation des autoroutes marine le
pen n'est pas la seule à l'avoir proposé
évidemment j'attends une réponse de
votre part sophie calle polian sur ce
terme d'infamie collé par la pression du
rassemblement national à la question des
véhicules diesel interdit dans les
centre-villes ce qui est quand même une
infamie c'est que de refuser de voir la
réalité c'est à dire qu'il ya plusieurs
milliers de morts par an liés à la
pollution à la pollution de l'air et moi
je suis une élue de banlieue vous savez
il ya beaucoup de familles n'ont pas les
moyens d'avoir une voiture donc c'est
pas le super bobo chaos ce duo là là
mais j'ai pas besoin d'une voiture moi
non il ya plein de personnes là où je
vis qui vont faire les grosses courses
du samedi les bras tout chargé a marché
pendant 15 minutes ou à prendre le bus
et c'est parce qu'ils n'ont pas de
voiture donc
ça suffit un peu les façons de pointe
est pointé du doigt les uns et les
autres et de faire des différences
qui sont parfois très artificielle et la
pollution de l'air qui est ce qu'elle
touche en premier évidemment souvent les
quartiers au bord du périphérique
donc les quartiers populaires qui en
prennent plein la gueule pardon de le
dire avec des écoles avec des crèches
etc etc ça c'est aussi une réalité à
prendre en compte après souvent quand
les personnes viennent de deux régions
vient de voir leurs familles viennent
visiter la capitale quand ils viennent
de banlieue lointaine mais certainement
qui viennent pas en voiture d'abord
parce que ça coûte très cher
ensuite c'est impossible de se garer
mais quand on vient à paris et c'est
pour ça que c'est une politique
intelligente de réduire la voiture dans
les grandes villes mais il ya des
transports en commun ils sont là ils
doivent être
multipliés ils doivent être améliorées
et c'est la raison pour laquelle
aujourd'hui je crois qu'on était tous
d'accord pour pour voter ce projet à
quelques aménagements près on a le grand
paris express qui va arriver qui va
permettre aussi des transports de
banlieue à banlieue c'est ça la réalité
de demain et c'est aussi le covoiturage
il faut peut-être arrêter de mettre la
voiture comme totem individuel de
réussite personnelle j'ai choisi telle
marque ou tel autre est de mieux
mutualiser tout cela c'est l'avenir je
crois et ne pas opposer les uns aux
autres mais se dire voilà dans telle ou
telle situation les uns et les autres
quelle est la meilleure solution pour
faire en sorte que ce soit une mobilité
réussi mais j'ajouterai part de vie en
france aujourd'hui il y à 75% de réseau
ferré de moins qu'il ya cent ans
peut-être aussi elle est là la question
jean viard dans le votre dernier livre
vous parlez delà de l'effet de la
pandémie vous dites que la pandémie nous
a changés est-ce qu'elle a modifié la
place de la voiture dans nos vies
mais moi je pense que la pandémie nous a
montré que le numérique était devenu le
premier lien entre les hommes alors que
depuis la dernière c'est le pétrole pour
le dire comme ça que ça sur la voiture
là breton le train d'avion etc quand je
pense que les cas des grandes périodes
historiques dans les liens entre les
hommes et qu'on a basculé dans une
civilisation numérique
le télétravail c'est ça la livraison à
domicile les 21 millions de clients
d'amazon etc non je pense qu'il faut
penser la société avec ça et deux
maillots radio locale et de la livraison
voyez moi par entend parler de l'âge des
voitures quoi pas très bien qu est-ce
que l'âge des voitures à faire dans la
discussion parce qu' il peut y avoir une
dynamique et une des voitures à
l'essentiel quand fois par semaine ça
pollue très peu alors que les taxis les
livraisons 20% des voitures arbitres
c'est les voitures de livraison pourquoi
sont-elles pas électrique six voitures
qui roulent énormément donc forcément on
comprend des critères d'ancienneté qui à
mon avis sont pas très favorable aux
milieux populaires on prend dix les
critères un peu différents puis je
terminerais une chose avait la mobilité
en ville c'est une conversation une
conversation que les handicapés qui
passe mal les mamans les vélos les
voitures les bus et ont dit les
transports en commun si vous connaissez
la ville comme vous la connaissez c'est
bien parce qu'on est d'ailleurs les gens
marchent de plus à pied à pied c'est le
pied qui progresse le plus en réalité un
mais quand vous allez dans une unique et
pas l'amour des transports en commun
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué il faut
faire regarder paris il ya deux millions
d'habitants il ya trois millions
personnes qui rendent tous les jours
dans la ville ici il faut que tous ces
gens là circulent dans la ville parce
que sinon la ville elle est morte elle
elle ne dit pas de ses habitants les
habitants ils sont comme dans les
légendes en une garce et les trains qui
font la guerre c'est pas les
fonctionnaires mais avec des
fonctionnaires est sincère je crois
qu'il faut un peu se dire la mobilité
c'est une conversation et le brassage
social je fais par la mobilité après on
peut discuter politique comme on veut il
nous reste avec rabin je voudrais qu'on
parle de cette autre proposition la
nationalisation des autoroutes on à
marine le pen jean-luc mélenchon et
arnaud montebourg qui qui le proposaient
comment c'est reçu cette idée
unanimement parce que encore une fois un
dès lors qu'on propose aux français de
baisser le coût de leur déplacement en
l'occurrence là en nationalisant les
autoroutes s'ils ont le sentiment que
donne beaucoup d'argent
pour le pour le priver d'une certaine
manière donc ça profiterait à tous et
français avec elle cette mesure très
largement donc voilà c'est vraiment on
est vraiment sur des sujets à la fois
on revient un peu à l'initiale de notre
débat c'est la voiture c'est aussi une
question d'argent c'est pas uniquement
une question de déplacement c'est aussi
une codification de pollution c'est
aussi une question de réchauffement
climatique donc on voit bien que ça
cristallise tous les sujets du moment
qui sont des sujets centraux et donc ça
fera sans doute la présidentielle de
2000 22 indirectement et jean louis
thiériot il faut nationaliser les
autoroutes écoutez je crois que on a mal
privatisée en tout cas quand je dis
qu'on a très mal pris baptisé c'est
qu'on a eu des des conventions mal faite
avec des taux de retour sur
investissement trop lourd enfin soyons
clair ça a été ça a été mal fait après
aujourd'hui la réponse n'est pas
évidente c'est que si on dit on
nationalise ça veut dire qu'on indemnise
les compagnies d'autoroutes ça veut dire
que les investissements que ce sont
quand même censé et que font les
compagnies d'autoroutes c'est l'état
c'est à dire le contribuable et qui va
le payer donc je voudrais qu'on est l'
équilibre entre le gard et le coût que
cela représente pour le français moyen
ce qui est clair en tout cas c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on doit tordre le bras à
un certain nombre de sociétés
concessionnaires moi je me suis battu
dans mes fonctions de parlementaire pour
obtenir la gratuité pour les pompiers et
les policiers qui empruntaient les
autoroutes on a mis un an et demi à
l'obtenir par décret et si vous alors
que ça avait été voté à l'assemblée
nationale et que les compagnies
d'autoroutes menaçait de partir dans des
recours ça a été à la deuxième question
d'actualité au gouvernement que le
gouvernement after du lebron campagne
automne ce qui est clair je ne sais pas
s'il faut privatiser mais en tout cas
faut leur torde le bras c'est faux les
nationaliser je ne sais pas s'il faut
les nationales match mais je crois
effectivement que il la privatisation
des autoroutes avec une erreur majeure
qui montre à quel point parfois il y à
une confusion totale entre l'intérêt
général et les intérêts privés et cela
est vraiment vraiment des exemples les
plus les plus les plus terribles donc
maintenant effectivement moi j'aimerais
bien que les candidats qui sont
favorables à la nationalisation moi je
suis favorable à cela il n'y a pas de
problème mais qu'on me dise
effectivement comment et comment on fait
parce que ça c'est très facile comme
effet de manche mais les contrats qui
sont passés sont terriblement liant
c'est absolument insupportable
nous avions proposé je me souvient
guillaume gontard le président du groupe
écologiste avait proposé un plan de
sortie qui a été rejetée par le
gouvernement parce qu'effectivement
contrat après contrat il faut tout
détricoter et si on veut pas se
retrouver avec des amendes insurmontable
c'est très difficile à faire et aucune
aucune eau la personne de me met en
place donc oui les tous les réseaux
doivent être des biens communs mais ça
doit pas se faire à n'importe quel prix
et il faut sortir en tout cas cette
confusion et que ce rapport au privé
d'avoir participé à ce débat rappelle le
le titre de votre livre jean louis
thiériot de go le dernier réformateurs
c'est chez tallandier et jean via la
révolution que l'on attendait est arrivé
aux éditions de l'aube